so we are delighted today to host
Douglas right
this year's Henry Paulson lecture so the
funding for this lecture series comes
from an anonymous donor in honor of
Henry L Stimson
college class of 1899 and that's picture
came up here on the left he was an
attorney and a statesman who had a whole
variety of government service that
culminates with the Secretary's tenure
and secretary wall during World War two
but also included stints as a US
Attorney Governor of the Philippines
Secretary of State's a very very rich
career and since 1998 the Macmillan
Center and the Yale University Press
have collaborated to use these lectures
as a chance to bring the most
distinguished scholars and practitioners
TL to lecture on topics that we then
published as books from the ill press
recent citizen lectures have included
talk by notable people such as Michael
Walter and it may use Susan dung John
marriage partner to Boston Ellison
so tonight speaker Doug ray and I can
tell from looking around the room that
he is known to many of you he first came
to Yale in 1967 as a junior faculty
member and the physical science
department he's not a truly
extraordinary distinguished career on
his bone economic systems and has
published very widely you're pretty good
consequences of electoral laws which was
still highly cited today and among
numerous articles and books along the
way he stopped a lot bombers through the
years too many to go through that all
dysfunction fuses an elected fellow of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences
a former Guggenheim Fellow a one-time
fellow of Stanford center to live and
study in the behavioral sciences and a
fellow of the Netherlands Institute for
Advanced Study we celebrate the Stimson
lectures somebody who has followed the
crowd yelled tradition of public service
and very often yell we celebrate people
who have performed that public service
of the highest national reaches of the
countries presidents Clinton Bush won
which to secti of state Supreme Court
justices and so on
don't raise record in public service I
think is something equally to be proud
of but has lived very much of the local
level he's been a resident of New Haven
for many many decades and in that time
he has sought in ways large and small to
improve the city and to improve the
lives of people in it he began in the
early nineteen eighties for instance to
start New Haven's first youth soccer
league when he got tired of driving his
kids to the suburbs and thought why
can't we make something like that here
accessible to all across the city that
put him on the map for some people if
somebody was interested in the city and
then he was contacted by
the Liotta to join the UN Commission on
poverty where he again met other people
in the city who recognized his knowledge
his expertise his people skills and his
genuine passion for improving the city
and that then put him on the radar of
Mayor John Daniels the first
african-american mayor of the city who
contacted him to be chief executive
officer and dr. public service lead for
a couple of years to serve in that
administration so this is somebody who
in many ways in his personal academic
life has really tried to live up to that
tradition of service and bring it home
here in New Haven lot of and outside and
that's something I think we should be
proud of tonight's talk is something
very different from from the New Haven
environments that we might know him
through he's currently writing a book on
American capitalism and teaching a
course on this topic the overarching
title of the book project is capitalism
knowledge drive as well and it's
focusing on three themes what the
American founders got wrong which is
today's lecture when markets forced
learning American in the 19th century
which is the topic that we're going to
tomorrow and now on Thursday that finale
is America's unequal calculus republic
which will be the last lecture and I
hope you join us for all the way so I'm
very very pleased to introduce my
department colleague Doug Wright
I should begin with two confessions or
perhaps more first tonight's lecture
will get we will get second the slides
are surreal I was warned by my good
friends in the in the teaching staff
that the slides should be reviewed
carefully before before we begin but I
ignored that good advice and I think all
the all the words are right some of the
pictures are simply absent if I got
we've got them all back you're brilliant
thank you
I want to begin with well what's
indicated by the slide a prologue a very
brief one about the the time in early
early modern late medieval early modern
times when intellectually almost
everything wonderful happened in a very
brief period this is my a list for I'm
calling this the green period so that I
don't have to distinguish between all
the wonderful things listed here which
represented an enormous f4f flowering
an enormous flowering of intellectual
brilliance and cultural innovation which
set the stage for the story we're going
to tell there are two things about the
green period that need mentioned one is
the brilliance of the intellectual
production the other is that they hadn't
yet begun to tear the world apart the
natural environment of the planet was by
1750 pretty much what it had been a
thousand years before technology was
shallow in the imprint it made on
Earth's crust the atmosphere remained
about the degree of concentration of
carbon which it had had for 800,000
years before
1750 I actually have a slide to
demonstrate that or to demonstrate it to
assert that I can't I can't quite say it
demonstrates it so we when capitalism
takes hold in the late 18th century it
inherits an enormous Commonwealth of
intellectual and cultural artifacts of
enormous lasting value and a relatively
clean slate in the natural environment
it changes both of those things during
the the green period this is what I
meant by slow-moving technology which
scratches the earth only a few inches
deep maybe a foot the idea that dilution
was a solution to pollution that just
flushing things into rivers was a an
effective and responsible thing to do
with chemical and biological waste and
capitalism capitalism changed all that
in a huge way it's created well here we
go this is the thesis of tonight's talk
take a second I won't recite it for you
well yes I will
capitalism coral corresponds with
increasing civility great great a great
surge in incomes and wealth accumulation
a quirky increase in the apparent
intelligence of children we'll explore
that and deeper than that is a social
intelligence carried by market economies
making it unnecessary for each
individual to master all the things
which will shape her life and enrich her
life
and finally dirtier capitalism has been
hell on the natural environment and
recovery from that will place great
strain on market and government
institutions and the reason to talk
about what the founders got wrong in the
second lecture and just to begin it
tonight at the end of the lecture is
that what they got wrong is they created
a defensive armature around national
power which made it easy to defend any
status quo arrangement however wasteful
however unfair and we are going to have
to make much more substantial changes
then our Constitution encourages going
forward finally and it would be
dishonest not to put this right it right
at the beginning capitalism generates
huge inequality and in the American case
very huge inequality economic insecurity
for millions of people incidentally
federal judges and universe at senior
university faculty our two groups immune
from that insecurity and should never be
listened to by anybody who works on a
contract with a length of less than
fifty years it's it's an astonishing
privilege that universities grant
faculty who hang around long enough so
let's get on with it
first of all what's capitalism I put
down five markers here
beginning with the observation that
capitalism is a way of arranging society
within a government capitalism the ein
Rand ideology of libertarianism has
seasoned opposition between government
and capitalism the way things actually
play out capitalism is a program for
government it is in many respects a
hands off or lays a fair program though
not in all and the central working of
capitalism would would be infeasible
without the powers of government here
I'm quoting Adam Smith the affluence of
the rich excites the indignation of the
or and it is
well I the Capitals in in PowerPoint
world is to put a thousand words on the
board and read them to people wealth is
unsustainable
substantial wealth is unsustainable
unsustainable in the absence of the
monopoly on force which governments
provide to the holders of that wealth
and this is this is a plain fact
recognized from the very beginning of
the liberal theories about capitalism
John Locke for example saw property as
the essential ingredient in the
construction of civil society and the
state I'm rubbing the point in here for
Smith it's a huge point though and
ideologically it is where I at least
part company with libertarian thinking I
have libertarian tendencies how many
wave if you've ever had a libertarian
reaction to some piece of legislation
make all of us have and as long as it's
piecemeal and we don't get around to
philosophical anarchism which would be
insufferable and intolerable and would
render all of us in a state of poverty
second main feature is that the means of
production are privately held or most of
them are privately held I mean quite
often there will be publicly owned
utilities there are in many cases
publicly owned airlines and railroads
but the capitalist the the chemistry of
a capitalist society
depends on there being a large sector
which is governed privately and is
governed without necessary attention to
the present the present agenda of the
state with a degree of independence
there we'll get to that momentarily
firms the third feature is that firms
are free to decide what they produce how
they produce it and who they employ in
producing it and how they go about
marketing it so there's chaos out there
there is a considerable degree of chaos
in any healthy capitalist economy I note
here if you look at the letter the
letter C at the top of the power of
Microsoft which is near very nearly a
monopoly includes the right to prevent
my combining the parens with the letter
C you can all try it if you type parent
C Parham you get trademark copyright
rather and so far as I know there's no
is there who Barry nalebuff probably
knows if there's a workaround is there
okay I I was able to like it's a pretty
good bad about you free labor is another
of the defining tenants and the
beginning of the American story of
course is entirely deficient in that
respect slave labor is wholly
inconsistent with the internal working
of capitalism those southern slave labor
played a huge role in supplying the
European textile industries the
Manchester cotton mills which were so
important in the 18th century at the
time of the American Founding
as I say in the bottom of the slide the
German word Vogel fry
free as a bird is used by marks and mark
sites to breathe irony on the concept of
free labor if the best job available to
me as a free worker is a dreadful job
badly paid I am free like a bird perhaps
but I am NOT free as a man most most
properly ought to hope to be finally
among the the defining characteristics
is a whole apparatus for the
accumulation and distribution of
knowledge universities are part of that
Yale is assuredly part of that all
public charities all 501 C 3
organizations which are exempt from much
most taxation are part of that and the
real functioning of the economy depends
on an educational system which produces
a flow of people with appropriate
knowledge and appropriate training and
the wealth this is no if there's one
overarching point in the Stimson
lectures I'm giving it is that the
ultimate basis of society's wealth is
the accumulation of practically valuable
knowledge and the recombination of that
knowledge in a continuous process of
innovation the name Harkness in Yale's
Harkins tower as I say here rhymes with
Standard Oil Stephen Harkness was in the
original group of seven who were
partners before
Standard Oil became a company so to sum
up one of the this one was highlighted
with yellow and the Machine decided to
get rid of that and maybe it was right
although there it is so these are the
things I think are important not as
defining characteristics of capitalism
but as consequences or correlates not
necessarily entirely caused by
capitalism indeed in some ways that
causal arrow may point in the opposite
direction for example it is very
difficult to operate in a market economy
if you are not reasonably civil and that
will tend over a period of generations
to shape your behavior so that if not
you then your children and grandchildren
learn a degree of civility which allows
them to function in a market system so
civility it has wide and narrow meanings
I have in mind two different strands one
of them is refraining from violence
another is good manners acting
respectfully toward other people there
when I say this it's a statistical
generalization
and like all other statistical
generalizations it's partly false that
is not his middle finger I am determined
here's the more nuts and bolts this is
from Steven Pinker's wonderful book the
better angels of our of our nature which
is a 600 year history of violence mainly
in the Western world but also worldwide
and these are noticed that it's a the
scale is exponentially graded it's a log
scale so that the distance between a
hundred and a thousand is given the same
space as the difference between 1 and 10
the this is an exceptional the US was an
exceptional place and there were local
pockets of very high violence in our
early history the Tennessee Kentucky
border country a Harlan County extremely
high rate of violence the big curve in
this chart is Virginia and the
Chesapeake where the rate of violence
goes from being pretty high to that is
100 per hundred thousand or 1 per
thousand down to being something like
what it is today this is a broader look
also from Pinker and the trend line for
Western Europe is representative of what
we're talking about and the downward
part of it that comes after 1648 and the
Treaty of Westphalia when the
nation-state system took hold
of Western Europe in a quite vigorous
way I didn't mean to flip that well and
the association between desisting from
violence and capitalism is again I don't
see it is a one-way correlation but it
is definitely there in the right hand
half of this chart this is another
another piece of research men well men
will honor who is a Cambridge Don does
statistical work on the history of
murder in European countries and the
Italians look pretty bad at the
beginning and stay that way until the
middle of this chart but then by the end
the homicide rate in all these places
has done the same thing it has verged
toward zero and the functioning of the
state in reducing homicide is a really
important story in pre state societies
and even when there's a nominal state
that doesn't have a real court system
and a real police function even in such
a state perhaps a third of all the
homicides are committed as punishment
for a prior homicide so that Smith kills
Jones's brother Jones then kills Smith
and we have two homicides whereas if it
is prosecuted by the state and the
punishment is less than hanging we have
one homicide and the concept of the
People vs Jones or
in my example the people versus this
person take it out of the binary
conflict picture and make it one in
which the act of homicide is seen as an
aggression against the society at large
now back to the civility to the soft
civility the good manners side of this
saying August agustin of Hippo believed
in a basically zero-sum world and so did
almost everybody in that era the idea
that two people trading could both get
to be better off by the trade which is
foundational to a market economy was
foreign to them the notion that trading
generated new value was foreign and was
a product of a later era the one we're
talking about Norbert Elias German
sociologist produced a book about that
thick which was a history of manners he
called it the civilizing process and it
was a history of increasingly civil
behavior in everyday life in German
society this is an unfortunate this is a
Nuremberg war trial the guy on the right
is a German officer who is being tried
for his life and the person I'm
interested in here is on his left and is
a guy named Albert Hirschman who became
a most distinguished economist spending
the plurality of his career at Princeton
there will frame him up and ignore the
Nuremberg and the book I'm interested in
here it was called the passions and the
interests and it was a history of
manners in Western Europe more specific
more pointed and I would say more
insightful than Ilyas history and the
example that jumps out for me is the
concept of avarice in the 17th century
avarice was considered the deadliest of
the deadly sins the most wretched
possible form of behavior was self
seeking about money and by the 18th
century avarice had come to be called
interest and was an accepted part of
human behavior it was what we expected
others to do there was no sense of sin
about trying to make a good living
operating a business or operating a
professional office or inventing new
stuff the fine print here mentions
another Hirshman book called exit voice
and loyalty 1970 and I just wanted to
mention that in 1969 when I was a
wet-behind-the-ears
beginner I had the privilege of an
invitation from her salon to go with him
and six other people to Italy and spend
a week drinking very good wine and
talking about the rough rough parts in
the manuscript for exit voice and
loyalty it's extraordinary quality had
nothing to do with my contribution or
anything else said that week but it was
one of the better weeks of my academic
life
Samuel Johnson there are very few more
innocent activities than getting money
and I think that's true I mean as long
as you're not scamming people making a
quote/unquote honest living is at the
core of a capitalist society Montesquieu
Montesquieu is important for several
reasons one of them is that the American
founders took him to be the state of the
art on how to organize a constitution
and the three the 3-way structure of our
state is taken straight from
Montesquieu's spirit of the laws he
makes the observation parallel to
Johnson really that there is a
correlation between Commerce and good
manners or gentleness the rise of the
state I already mentioned this I should
rub in the idea that the state takes
over the revenge motive from civil
society in 15th century Europe any
well-to-do gentleman would carry a
dagger everywhere he went and would be
prepared to use it if properly provoked
such behavior would for this crowd be
implausible I carry a pocket knife left
at home tonight about that big and it
doesn't count
although TSA at the airport will
shamelessly confiscate it every time
richness and wealth
this is more
what when it would expect in this topic
and it is central this is a diagram
FEMA it's a rather famous diagram by
Gregory Clark he has a chapter which he
calls a 16 page economic history of the
world and there's my ranee and what he
says but income per person where 1800 is
one unit on the vertical scale and he's
generalizing about Western Europe here
there is no systematic growth in the
years before 1800 Clark rubs that in by
saying that a working-class person in
England in that year lived a harder life
than a caveman a hundred thousand years
earlier and how would we verify that I
have no idea their condition was not not
softer wonderful the important part of
his of his chart is a near vertical
swing which the economy of Western
Europe took around the Year 1800 and
which has had an enormous an enormous
impact on the planet and on the way
people people live today I'll drown you
in statistics here these are estimated
average GDP per capita so the size the
total size the economy divided by the
number of people for all these
capitalist countries and the the u.s. is
probably are probably your central focus
there is a huge increase in the economic
activity occurring in a given year from
starting in 1800 and finishing up in two
hundred years later in the in the
millennial year it's a very steady story
and it's one which plays out in all
these rich countries what they have in
common is that they all became
capitalists by the mid point of the 19th
century they became capitalists and as a
result on average much richer than they
had been before now this is a chart
about death rates and it ties into
understanding the next stat I'm going to
throw at you the the time scale is from
the year 15:41 to the year 1975 each dot
is a year's overall death rate per
thousand in England and the data are
pretty good they're surprisingly
reliable the working question was done
by Robert Fogel at the University of
Chicago and the yellow zone is roughly
speaking the capitalist era the era
where fairly well developed state state
the state is rather well developed or
beginning to be and the capitalist
economy is beginning to grow rapidly
there are two obvious obvious contrasts
between the earlier period and white and
the later period in yellow and there
these I believe one is that there is no
systematic
trend in the death rate up to the
transition that is from 1541 - let's say
1750
there's fluctuation but no systematic
trend or if there is a trend it's flat
that's one point the other is that death
rates are highly variable in that period
you have years where death rates are
above we have one year or it's above
fifty per thousand five percent per year
that's a lot of death and it's not rare
to get above 35 or 40 as a death rate in
that early period well the second period
has two differences and they're the ones
you would expect from what I just said
first there is a systematic downward
trend in the death rate death becomes
less frequent the rates fall from the
neighborhood of 30 per thousand or 3% to
10 or 15 per thousand or just over 1%
and modern death rates are lower than
that but not very much lower that is
1975 here shows at about 10 and there
are very few advanced economies where
the death rate is a lot lower than 10
per thousand the other is that the
variation is gone the the law the dots
are very closely packed around the
trendline from the late 1800s to the end
of the data so that phenomena like
plagues and famine
are being driven out of the economy
people died terrible things happen but
they don't happen on a mass scale in
ways that are unexpected and
unpredictable this chart this table
rather shows lifespan GDP per capita so
it takes into account both what the GDP
is and how long you live so that if
someone was born in the year 1800 with a
life expectancy of 40 years we would add
up an estimate of GDP for 1800 1801 1802
and so on for the 40 years of life
expectancy take that sum and write it
down here the dramatic increase in these
numbers represent the combined effect of
sustained economic growth and strongly
increasing longevity or put backward
strongly diminishing death rate the
United States is not the not at the top
of the pack but near it and and is
fairly typical you see two blank cells
for the United States there can you take
a guess what those might be why they
would be there there were no data about
slaves so computing the overall rate
would be meaningless
this chart is here just it's India which
is in a period of enormous
enormous growth from a very low base and
the worldwide story
the reason globalization means the
movement of manufacturing jobs toward
Asia and toward the southern hemisphere
has everything to do with the fact that
the capitalist the capitalist surge is a
hundred years later in those places than
in the northern hemisphere and the
Western Hemisphere in Europe and the
offshoots of Europe like North like the
US Canada New Zealand Australia and
ultimately one would suppose that there
would be a convergence in the degree of
wealth between the western and northern
countries and the rest of the world and
the Chinese are peddling really hard and
using fairly strong incentives to make
that happen as fast as they can
smart people got smarter in the 20th
century this is a weird story it's
called the Flynn effect is Flynn is that
a name any anybody recognizes ok guys
name is James B Flynn
he was a cognitive psychologist and IQ
test IQ what's the average IQ of the
test taking public it's always the same
100 and Flynn was involved in rewriting
the tests from year to year and they
discovered a systematic
and if they left the questions the same
or change the questions and made them
the same degree of difficulty IQs kept
rising it happened throughout the
developed world and it went on it's no
longer happening but it went on for
about nearly 50 years and it was
substantial the fluid intelligence is
not much influenced by schooling it's
giving people a pictorial matrix and
having them analyze it and seeing how
well they do at that and the rise was
about 15 points per generation so if you
if you take a generation to be 25 or 30
years that's a pretty big shift in what
what sounds to me like just Ross Marx
and that's quite remarkable
crystallized IQ means using established
procedures like Algebra one or geometry
or other other things that are taught in
schools and there the effect of the
Flynn effect was more modest it was only
about half or a little more than half
what it was for fluid IQ and the
question of course becomes why is this
happening and one thing I think we can
rule out is evolution the you jet the
this was a startling revelation to
eugenicist eugenics people had the
starting point that the the observation
France installed in eighteen
eighty-three says all the smart people
are not having children or having few
children and all these dumb people
working in the factories are generating
the next year the next generation of our
citizens what a horror we will be Dumber
generation by generation and as it
happened the Flynn effect refutes that
there was no systematic this
dysfunctional devolution the I don't
know why this happened and nobody knows
the likeliest bet is that more kids were
spending more years in school that's one
too that people got better about
managing time and doing the test in a
smart way where you quickly fill in what
you know and don't spend time scratching
your chin about things you don't know
how to solve another possibility is that
with a culture has been shifted from a
narrative focus to an analytic focus a
narrative focus understands any problem
by telling a story in chronological
sequence a analytic focus does something
very different and something much more
like what IQ tests are interested in so
that's another of the possibilities this
is more a more important point for our
subject than the Flynn effect this is FA
Hyack and this is something I believe is
not only true but profoundly true is
among the most important facts
about a society like our own it is that
as the total Commonwealth of knowledge
is built up generation after generation
and within generations year after year
the ratio between what is carried in any
one cranium and what is available to
that cranium when it listens to the
world is gets steeper and steeper we are
all relative to our time and place more
limited now than at any time in the past
not because we have declined but because
the commonwealth of knowledge around us
has expanded exponentially and it is
expanding at a rapidly increasing rate
every year and when you read the scary
stuff about artificial intelligence the
scary point is how much useful knowledge
there is to plug in to artificial
intelligence even if it's net generated
generation of new knowledge were
negligible Hayek is a wild-eyed market
conservative or was I met him once he
was in a wheelchair and was trying his
best to be nice I mean I was many
degrees of the compass too far left for
his taste and still AM although I
probably moved a degree or two his way
so the for me the central point about
smart is social smarts the smarts which
are held in common across society the
knowledge the how-to the ability to
construct and reconstruct better devices
better procedures is now far greater
than it was at any previous point in our
history oh yeah this is called I've I
don't have time to tell you this I'll
tell it to those of you who come next
time no he'll that's the best bad
behavior that's uncivil here it is this
is a story of written by a master
student at University College London who
sets out to make a an electric toaster
from scratch and spins
I forget the number I think it's about
50,000 pounds and makes the object shown
on the cover of the book which will get
a little warm but will not toast bread
this is hi exploit my axe point is that
the pooled knowledge which is out there
and accessible to people making toasters
and not accept not accessible to people
using toasters is of profound importance
and the way we the way we get on with
our lives is to rely at increasing rates
on knowledge generated by strangers for
us and for millions of others like us
Ernest Gellner just I'm curious how many
of you have ever heard the name Ernest
Gellner okay people with a little
sociology he was one of the greats he
was an industrial sociologist and he
makes this point this is another way of
making high export it is that the
vocabulary people in an industrial
economy speak is different from the
vocabulary of any other society or type
of society and is better not more poetic
but better from a pragmatic point of
view from the point of view of getting
from purpose to process to product the
vocabulary of an industrial society like
our own is extremely powerful part of it
is math of course but lots of it is not
math but words organized around the
commonwealth of knowledge I've been
making a Jeff repeated economic
knowledge myself I'm going to finish in
four minutes there is a kind of self
generating evolution in the way a market
works and the importance of the of
companies having free rein in choosing
what they do and how they do it and who
they hire to execute it is important
because it creates variation in the way
people the ways let's say toasters the
way people make toasters I've actually
gone to a store and that had 40 kinds of
toasters and there are they all are
about the same idea but they vary it in
sometimes uninteresting but sometimes
interesting ways and then the selection
from past accomplishments that get
folded into new things is central to the
way our society works
I made that chart this chart
last night I had had a tumbler of
bourbon and I think maybe we'll just
pass I'll go to I'll go to an example
about selection from the 1840s this is
when the railroads were suddenly
becoming central to the American economy
the British economy and several European
continental continental European
economies and and the story I'm going to
tell you is about the US and the
strategy in the u.s. was to raise the
capital and then throw rails out there
build lots of trackage just to get the
revenue start and do it somewhat
helter-skelter and they had trouble from
that they used wrought iron for the
rails and they supported the rails on
stone or cement the ties as we call them
were made of stone or cement or wood and
would one out why did why would would
have one out because they found a
correlation the rate at which the
wrought iron delaminated and killed
people which it did often it would it
would just it just ceased to be a unit
we just splay out all over the place due
to the weight of the trains and the rate
at which the wrought iron delaminated
was lower with wooden ties because the
ties were soft enough to absorb some of
the pressure made would the better
product
soon after that of course they decided
wrought-iron was the wrong product and
the steel industry was ultimately the
result of that and steel which had been
a monstrously expensive metal in 1840
became a commercially available and not
terribly expensive on the order of $30 a
ton two generations later Oh dirtiness
this is a picture of trash this this
tells what it is it's the Cuyahoga River
and Cleveland on fire with the epaulets
from the oil refineries children living
in a dump Rachel Carson Carlson's Silent
Spring how many of you read that book
when it came out oh I forgot my people
the only old person here I mean I well I
was I was a college senior when it came
out and I actually didn't read it I just
read the reviews and got the point which
is pretty powerful the larger point is
the carbon in our atmosphere this is a
chart generated by NASA and I am it
covers 800,000 years with horizontal
line representing the level at night in
1950 the level of co2 you see random
fluctuation within tight
limits for 800,000 years and then you
see it double more or less in a few
generations that should scare us off and
it will set a task for the next
generation of people living in
capitalist and industrial economies like
our own and I will stop there having
exceeded my time limit already thank
we'll take a few questions for those who
couldn't remain yeah it is that the
delegates from Virginia were the
intellectual leaders Hamilton in New
York was another they were here they
were these were two very prosperous
colonies and they were teaming up with
eleven nondescript colonies and they
were going to throw their lot in with a
National Alliance of those thirteen and
they thought defensively it was easy for
them to imagine a coalition which was
adverse to their interests Virginia it
was really easy because of slavery and
abolitionism throughout the northern
colonies New York which under Hamilton's
leadership was conspicuously fond of
bankers and investors or as they said
speculators and they they rigged the
Constitution to make change slow and
difficult separation of powers checks
and balances the core of the theory is
in Federalist number 51 and I guess
Federalist 51 and Federalist 1010 says
make the country as big and
heterogeneous as possible so that nobody
can organize a majority coalition and
that turned out to be a sounder bet in
the 1780s then it has been at any time
since so that's what they did and
the the difficulty the the costliness
and incoherence of policymaking where
with something like health care or
climate change you have to move the
whole thing in a systematic way the
whole corpus of Public Policy has to
shift in a coordinated way which
Obamacare and I'm an Obama Obama fan but
Obamacare doesn't even begin to do it in
a coordinated way it does it in a
completely uncoordinated way and the
Constitution made the task when they did
the Obama health care act almost
impossible they had to concede side
payments to every imaginable interest
group most of all to the insurance
industry and created well our healthy
who knows what percentage of our GDP
goes to health care around 18 we're
spending about twice what we ought to be
spending and are we getting results that
are even as good as the cheapskates in
Canada no our Constitution forces to get
any sustained change that's that complex
is a very slow process and requires
extraordinary leadership at many levels
at once yes I absolutely and my my a
listers included Francis Bacon for
example for that reason the
science is well there's a really
interesting lab for this right now at
MIT where they are doing venture capital
starting with ideas from MIT science
people trying to solve design and
engineering issues an order of magnitude
or two orders of magnitude more
difficult than we're used to this is
called the MIT engine and is there for
example have a they have started a new
firm to do Fusion Energi Commonwealth
fusion company another company to make
steel without all the energy and heat
that is involved in every existing way
of making steel so they're taking big
leaps the role of I mean if you think
about the transistor for example Bell
Labs and then shot William Shockley
associates and then he a lien Aidid all
his engineers at once and they went off
to form Fairchild Semiconductor I think
that's the name and science is at the
very heart of that and I think it's it's
woven through all this I may have
shortchanged it in the examples I
selected sure
and you will note that partly the green
period is is a gesture about covariance
and the way I formulated it's not causal
it's not that capitalism causes civility
for example it is equally the the
obverse the civility promotes capitalism
colonialism was on a halt
in aggregate a terribly important way of
extracting resources and cheap labor
from other societies and I guess one way
to put your question is imagine the
capitalism developed with no colonial
colonial umbrella around it could it
have been what it is and I I don't know
the answer to that I gonna take a guess
I would say yes it could have done it it
would have done it in a different and
probably inferior way but it would have
been something like what we're talking
about yes it's a great survey of
things contribute to capitalism and I
was thinking many of them do relate to
China but how is our major competitor in
the society that is growing economically
so rapidly what features is it missing
is it promotion of these features that
you described and they could have all of
them the only way in which it is
odd-man-out
is the nature of its state is quite
different this Chinese state is utterly
different from the western states I was
mainly talking about and for I for 30
years harbored the view that as the
Chinese economy got more and more open
more and more overtly capitalist that
the government would be compelled to
embrace a more open system of governance
and quite the opposite has happened and
I find that sad and well beyond my
understanding about why it broke in that
way do you see the competition obviously
the knowledge is great
it's as competitive as they choose to
let it be in any given instance and you
might say that about our society by the
way these days I mean the very large
platform companies have endured inant
market power Amazon and Facebook for
example and one of the one of the
examples about us
governance is antitrust and the
generally unsuccessful character of
antitrust legislation I mean the the
shirin Act of 1890 had one effective
consequence which was the division of
Standard Oil into 34 little companies in
1911 but nothing else and there were
lots and lots of monopolies and near
monopolies in the period we're talking
about and the Congress never got around
to making it I have teeth that would
actually change monopolistic practices
on a mass scale
the breaking up the Standard Oil had one
consequence for john d rockefeller which
was that it made him roughly five times
richer than he was before the breakup
and i don't know if you count that as a
victory or not
probably not
[Music]
opponents all the electronic devices we
use we have a much larger world so it's
a little nice to see that the nice
things have built in the Metropole but
quite a lot of the waste and increased
inequality and in fact some extremely
awful things all together and include
the hinterland in the capitalist system
you might get a very different feel for
how successful it is your facts are I
think dad on there is actually a very
good book called the one product which
is about the iPhone and and the
extractive network that puts that
together from I don't know what it is
the Raman there are hundreds of
different metals and other raw materials
that go into it and I would say I
certainly agree that a full analysis of
capitalism would include what you're
calling the hinterlands or what Sean
Thunder is has in mind for colonial
societies like 19th century and well
it's an interesting question my own
intuition and there's no serious
research behind it is that the role of
most metals will be diminishing over
time going forward the pred the rare
earths and certain other metals will
remain very important
perhaps become more important and scare
sir but mood the sort of heavy movement
of stuff is a lower fraction now of the
economy than it was any previous time I
don't I don't doubt the major point you
have in mind this actually connects a
lot of these recent comments which is
that how much does this rise of
capitalism especially mature capitalism
how much does it depend on corporate
structures and so how much is this a
history of corporatization as opposed to
markets and is there a possibility for
capitalism without you know global
corporate structures it's a good
question Charlie the the the corporation
of course goes back to the very
beginning I mean the East India Company
was a was a joint stock corporation the
Virginia Company was the Massachusetts
Bay Company was so the corporate the the
freely minted corporation where some
entrepreneurs without going to the
government can sit down around a table
the way the Standard Oil guys did in
1870 that's a recent phenomenon that
only starts about 1840 with the British
Corporations Act and it's analogue in
the American States now I think the the
joint stock corporation and other
structures a lot like it are pivotal to
this end if you took them away
people were that people would have to
invent something a lot like them that
evaded the law the well I mean if you
think about the Standard Oil story they
created the trust to get around state
laws and it worked it worked so well
that ultimately they got the Sherman Act
in 1890 which kills one company didn't
even kill it just metastasized it made
it far less monopolistic except that
John Dee had a finger in all 34 pots
well thank you all for coming
[Applause]
[Music]